this is going to sound like I'm
insulting you but you're single correct
I want you to guess how I knew Jesus
no I said I wasn't going to insult you
I'm not a kid wasn't what I was thinking
at all you're not even fat have
confidence dude that might be why you're
single you don't know how great you are
but you know how I knew you were single
what do you have that these two don't
Joy you don't really want to laugh he
just hit his face in his palm and he was
saying it to me like bro shut the
up I'm already not happy I don't need
her to yell at me about how she made me
not happy these are good men they gave
you all their happiness all their best
te that's what I'm doing I love my wife
to death dude